provinces across the country are slowly
emerging from the pandemic tomorrow
ontario and nova scotia scrapped most of
their indoor mask requirements but as
ross lord reports canada's top health
officials warn the pandemic is far from
over
after two years of facial coverings that
have annoyed some canadians and
infuriated others each passing week
brings more flexibility it's personal
freedom
on both sides definitely ready to take
off that mask if i go to a large group
like a hockey game or something i'll
probably still going to wear a mask etc
but
there's some times that it's nice not to
wear a mask like on a nice sunny day
like today coinciding with the arrival
of spring nova scotians are about to
breathe a sigh of relief no more
required distancing no more gathering or
capacity limits and at the same time as
ontario no more automatic masking except
for high risk settings and classrooms
most staff will probably keep their
masks on for the first little bit to
assess the situation
i'll definitely keep wearing my mask
proof of vaccine requirements are also
being removed other than in health care
settings with fewer canadians in
hospital the majority of other provinces
have already eased covet 19 restrictions
setting higher vaccine rates and a need
to guard mental health and the economy
but public health messaging on masks can
seem contradictory with the omicron ba2
variant causing infectious to rise again
in some parts of the world canada's top
doctor suggests it's too soon to resign
masks to the garbage heap of history
we're in a period of uncertainty
where um
you know the the virus is still
undergoing evolution so getting up to
date with vaccines plus wearing a mask
is still a really good idea as more
restrictions are lifted dr tams says a
spring bump in cases should not be
surprising the hope is ba2 outbreaks
will be offset by people enjoying warmer
weather outside where the virus spreads
more slowly hope also springs eternal
the canadians will respect each other's
decisions when it comes to issues like
if and when to mask up
ross lord global news